it's not the opinion of others that  bother me it's the opinion of myself so  are there any strategies for blocking  out the negative opinion oneself can  have about themselves absolutely either  your mother or your father put that  negative opinion about yourself in your  head once you realize that that's true  then you stop [ __ ] on yourself and  realize somebody else made you do that  and you start the process of loving  yourself  we are not born to think we suck it is  instilled in the insecurities or  negativities of the people around us and  by the way this doesn't mean you should  hate your parents they were doing that  because that happened to them but you  need to understand that that voice is  not in your head